joining me on the phone is a long time
reporter and columnist covering the
colts in indianapolis he is writing for
WTHR calm as well as appearing on that
television station bob kravitz now on
the rich eisen show how are you Bob good
when you said you wanted someone to
bring it you're referring to me yes that
is correct bob weir well i will bring
the funk wonderful so Bob let me ask you
where are you right now are you in an
airport where are you Bob like I think
anything good I don't know what's on
here well we we got planes all over the
place okay so what are the colts do in
this is it just purely andrew luck
putting the team on his shoulders and
everybody else is following or there are
some unsung heroes that we're not
talking about well I mean you know you
needed to be taught by offense or at
least had a pretty good sense of it you
know with registry coming back and you
know I would spot a chocolate so I mean
they've held up in the bargain but the
reason revelation is the disputants it's
it's a top-five defense in the top five
in most categories third down
conversions they've only allowed four
other last 41 third down conversions
that I mean guys like yarn burner have
really emerged Ricky jean-francois
picking the place of officer Jones Erik
Walden has been very good Cory Redding
this time like he's 25 again so there's
a lot of guys I mean this is the most
you know it really you have to come back
two thousand five to find a gymnast a
post that that's complete in terms of
offense defense and special teams that
is saying quite something how
sustainable is it do you think uh you
know as long as they can continue in the
password at 21 SAT after getting some
very good games against against peyton
the Philadelphia Eagles and they've been
on a roll ever since I mean it's it's
really common
named defense I mean kun is not that one
bell cow God you say you've got a game
plan for him but they're just getting
from everywhere like I say Vernors being
very very good I think I don't know that
defensively that's necessarily that's
sustainable I think that there's a good
defense I felt all along like a pro top
15 defense they could go a long way in
the pushing because they're that good
offensively how good is andrew luck you
know i'm just sitting here looking at
the staff through the other MVP
candidate and he's right and i think
there are four or five guys who are all
in the same mix you know Rogers Peyton
Manning Philip Rivers busy wife are
calmer his numbers are right there he
get back a little bit less football
strong seven interceptions not all his
fault duh he snaps her babies he's kind
of a combination of Ben Roethlisberger
and Eric Rogers ability to Stan's pocket
and place Bob we appreciate you joining
us next time when we get John hopefully
we'll get a better a little bit better
of a connection but but appreciate your
thoughts the Rich Eisen show weekdays at
noon eastern on audience